[Música]
hace unos años trabajé en la
coordinación nacional antisecuestro y me
tocó desafortunadamente atender un caso
de tres mujeres brutalmente mutiladas en
el momento de su cautiverio tres
hermanas
fue un caso muy duro porque al momento
que las víctimas regresaron al momento
que el papá terminó de negociar el
secuestro empezaba apenas la pesadilla
ante la ineficiencia del sistema el papá
tuvo que darse a la tarea invertir todos
sus recursos en buscar a los
secuestradores de su hija él no iba a
descansar hasta que encontrara a los
culpables del gran daño que le habían
hecho a su hija
cuando los encontró prácticamente se los
entregó
al juez a las autoridades y los
detuvieron detuvieron a siete de a ocho
y cuando no detenían al octavo el papa
fue y habló con el juez y les dijo hoy
no entiendo por qué no detienen a este
ya se los puse seriales y se la llama
y el juez se le volteó y dijo
al señor la tenemos a siete de los
secuestrados de su hija
encarcelados todo quiere uno más y cito
no sea goloso le dijo el juez el
problema
desafortunadamente el sistema de
justicia penal en nuestro país está
completamente rebasado eso no es algo
nuevo no vengo a contarles y mucho menos
en este espacio en esta institución
que tenemos un sistema completamente
fracasado
y para todos para las víctimas para los
victimarios y también para las
autoridades que se dedican a la justicia
penal en nuestro país todos los días
escuchamos historias de víctimas
van a levantar una denuncia las pocas
víctimas que van a levantar una denuncia
de un delito y se confrontan con cosas
tan básicas que parecieran que la
corrupción y la impunidad está
completamente sistematizada y metida en
nuestro sistema de justicia penal donde
el hecho de que te levante en una
denuncia implica que tengas que dar una
mordida o al momento que te están
levantando la denuncia el ministerio
público te va asesorando de qué decir
para que se procesen a tu victimario
aunque los hechos no sean los que están
poniendo en ese documento no está de más
no se no se deja de ver que como víctima
de secuestro por ejemplo se acerca
contigo el judicial y te diga ese que
ves ahí ese es el líder de la banda de
los secuestradores yo sé que tú no lo
conoces pero tienes que decir que lo
viste tienes que decir y las víctimas se
repitiese revictimicen constantemente
cuántas veces no hemos escuchado de
sembrado de drogas de dinero
para poder procesar
escuchar que el ministerio pública de
licenciada 11 que quiere hacer la chamba
bien pero desafortunadamente no siempre
se puede sabemos que las culpables y que
no se preocupe lo vamos a solucionar y
la sembrada no con los victimarios es lo
mismo las cárceles están llenas de
mujeres y hombres que te cuentan
historias de terror de sus detenciones
la falta de investigación que tiene el
sistema de justicia penal ha hecho que
la
quiero decir tortura pero estoy pensando
en otra palabra este la tortura
para levantar una declaración
se vuelva una cosa de todos los días y
desafortunadamente eso acaba poniendo a
los verdaderos delincuentes en la calle
otra vez las faltas de herramientas que
tienen los investigadores penales en
nuestro país hace que las declaraciones
o las mismas declaraciones de los
victimarios donde ellos se declaren
culpables sea el único herramienta que
tengan para procesar jurídicamente y
finalmente
a alguien las historias de mujeres que
son como mujeres violentadas al momento
de su detención como son usadas sus
hijos para que se declaren culpables
ante un delito no nada más hecha el
sistema de seguridad para atrás en
nuestro país pero también habla de las
pocas herramientas que cuentan las
autoridades
para hacer su trabajo y hacerlo bien las
autoridades están rebasadas
abogado defensor de oficio tiene
promedio en méxico cinco audiencias al
día promedio por audiencia de dos horas
esto quiere decir que la audiencias nada
más en un día son diez horas a mí que me
expliquen a qué hora leen un expediente
a quiero estudian un expediente
el juez no tiene la más mínima
protección del estado y se confronta con
casos complejísimos donde muchas veces
su integridad y de su familia son
vulneradas si no se ven ante una
situación
de hacerle caso a un posible victimario
no
siempre que hablo de corrupción y de
impunidad en el sistema me retomo a una
plática que tuve hace unos años cuando
estábamos haciendo el perfil de
secuestradores a nivel nacional con el
mochaorejas en el arizmendi que para mí
es quien marcó el ritmo del secuestro en
nuestro país y me quedé fría me quedé
helada en el momento que me platicaba
que cuatro años antes de que fuera
detenido había sido detenido entonces
cien por ciento ya detenido como está
ahorita ya sin haber salido había sido
detenido previamente y que le había
entregado doscientos mil pesos a un juez
para que le dictara su libertad cuando
me contó eso yo pensaba doscientos mil
pesos no es nada comparado con las
orejas que se cortaron después de que
salió a desmentir de la cárcel no es
nada con las víctimas que sufrieron el
cautiverio de estar en las manos de los
hermanos arizmendi no es nada con los
que hoy no
en vida porque la familia no pagó el
rescate
su familiar
es urgente que humanicemos
nuestros expedientes es urgente que
entendamos que si pretendemos acercar a
la sociedad civil con nuestro sistema de
justicia penal si pretendemos hablar de
prevención del delito tenemos que
entender que tenemos que acercar a la
sociedad en méjico el 97 por ciento de
los delitos no se denuncian
eso es una cifra que todos decimos y lo
decimos dientes para fuera
pensémoslo bien 97 por eso hace el la
delincuencia en méxico rentable de 100
delitos que cometas probablemente te van
a ganar en uno eso es absurdo cuando
hablamos de seguridad y cuando hablamos
de un país que está con los niveles de
violencia como los que tenemos nosotros
en nuestro país
y también humanizar un expediente y
entender que en esas hojas que tenemos
en nuestros ministerios públicos
son personas de carne y hueso personas
que sienten presuntas que han vivido un
agravio
victimarios que están su libertad
presuntos victimarios que está su
libertad en en duda según lo que diga
ese expediente entonces podemos hablar
de prevención del delito si nos damos
cuenta y especialmente un espacio como
estos que ser personajes autoridades
claves en la creación y en el cambio en
nuestro sistema de justicia penal es
hablar de un méxico más seguro es hablar
de un méxico donde predomine la
seguridad y también es entender que
nadie estamos exentos de un día ser
parte del sistema de justicia penal yo
prácticamente una o dos veces a la
semana recibo una llamada telefónica con
alguien llorando diciéndome licenciada
me dieron su teléfono por favor ayúdenme
y la frase terminando en nunca pensé que
esto nos pasaría a nosotros y ese es el
problema la cárcel está ya le pasa a
ellos a mí no el sistema de ajuste de su
penal está ya le pasa a ellos no me pasa
a mí
hace unos meses me tocó ir al reclusorio
norte aquí en la ciudad de méxico porque
nos había llegado la solicitud de una
inocente en prisión y la inocencia en
prisión no me sorprendió pero lo que sí
me sorprendió fue que era un judicial
que estaba acusado por secuestro si yo
mismo fui a entrevistarlo
y me dijo no se licencia yo no yo no yo
no secuestra a nadie
la verdad es que usted sabe cómo está el
sistema donde la corrupción está si se
hacen los costos iniciados o yo ya sabía
perfectamente bien las deudas las cuotas
que teníamos que entregarle al jefe ya
sabíamos que si llegaba la familia de un
detenido pues dependiendo como vea
veíamos la situación pues la pedrada no
sabíamos cuando teníamos que sembrar el
arma la droga o el dinero
y esa misma dinámica es la misma
sistematización y sistematización de la
corrupción en el cual él ya tenía como
parte de su trabajo diario lo llevó a
estar sentado vestido de beige en el
reclusorio norte un día
lo mandaron hubo una denuncia un pitazo
de un posible secuestro en un almacén
y fue lo mandaron a ver que se trata de
bebé a ver qué onda me dijo el jefe se
agarró con dos o tres de sus compañeros
y fueron a ver de qué se trataba y bueno
a ver de qué se trataba porque iban a
ver si se podían arreglar si valía la
pena de quién se trataba así era alguien
con el cual ya traía ese ministerio
público acuerdos específicos sobre sí
si se daba chance uno se daba chance y
la sorpresa que se llevó señor fue que
en el momento que él estaba viendo qué
onda también la fiscalía antisecuestros
de la ciudad de méxico había recibido el
pitazo de ese mismo secuestro al momento
de que llegaron
a ver qué onda también llegó a hacer la
detención la fiscalía antisecuestros y
lo metieron en el com parte de la banda
de secuestradores que estaba operando en
ese mismo espacio y se decía inocente
y yo cuestionaba es o no es inocencia
está tan sistematizado no está
sistematizado y estamos tan
deshumanizados también yo algo que
argumento todos los días es urge que
normalicemos y que metamos y nosotros
vemos de hablar de salud mental adentro
de nuestro sistema de justicia penal
cuando entrevistar muchas orejas me subí
pasaron por milos de la coordinación
anti secuestro del estado de jalisco
donde está ponte grande
y yo cómo era parte del equipo yo venía
a la policía federal me contaban que
tenían a un detenido pero que no lo
habían podido presentar porque es
tremenda golpiza que le habían metido el
momento de tenerlo entonces es que lo
tenían en situación delicada pero tan
pronto lo sacaran de ella lo iban a
presentar
y es que licenciado usted no sabe lo que
es este hijo de la chingada hablaba y le
decía a la mamá que iba a violar a su
hija y que tal yo le hice a ver cómo
ustedes negociaron el secuestro sí y
ustedes también fueron y recogieron a la
dirección y cierto sí y nosotros hicimos
absolutamente no se puede no se puede
pretender que no podemos hablar de salud
mental en nuestras autoridades del
sistema de justicia penal y que el
sistema funcione
es momento de que nos atrevamos a hacer
las cosas distinto es momento que nos
atrevamos a apostar por un sistema de
justicia penal humanizado donde el
expediente lo entendamos y lo vivamos
como humanos que están sufriendo y que
están viviendo una cosa que nadie nos
gustaría vivir
encabezó una organización que se llama
reinserta una organización que trabaja
con personas privadas de la libertad y
que cree en la reinserción social como
un eje clave en materia de seguridad en
nuestro país hace un par de años cuando
la ley de adolescentes entró en vigor la
nueva ley de adolescentes entró en vigor
un juez se previo a hacer las cosas
diferentes no tenga nada que perder y
nosotros estábamos trabajando con un
chavito de 16 años que había matado a su
novia de 16 años
él estaba pidiendo salir un par de meses
antes de que se terminara su
su condena el juez habló con nosotros
nos dijo yo como ven ustedes este chavo
no
yo creo que podemos trabajar con él es
lo que quiero hacer es si le vamos a dar
la libertad anticipada quiero que esa se
la otorgue en la mama de la mujer que me
alto
me parece interesante que la justicia
restaurativa está dentro de la ley no
bien hagámoslo el juez está previo y
logramos sentar a este chavo a este
menor de edad que tenía todavía toda una
vida por delante porque la ley así lo
marcaba con una mujer cuya hija había
asesinado
nos metieron en un cuartito durante 4
horas platicaron y al final el juez le
preguntó a la mamá la otorga a usted la
libertad anticipada a este joven ya le
dijo sí sí pero me tienes que prometer
le dijo
que todos los días de tu vida te vas a
parar y vas a ser un hombre de bien yo
no quiero que exista una mamá que esté
sufriendo igual de lo que estoy
sufriendo yo hoy el es el chavo que se
ha graduado de mi programa de
reinserción social más rápido ya lo
promovieron tres veces en la empresa en
la que trabaja y está estudiando
ingeniería meco mercado esas cosas que
yo no puedo decir es que ingenierías muy
complicadas en el politécnico
es un chavo que sabe que está endeudado
con la sociedad y es un chavo que hoy no
va a volver a cometer un delito entonces
atrevemos nos atrevamos nos a hacer las
cosas diferentes y atrevámonos a
humanizar los expedientes
atrevámonos a volver a acercar a la
sociedad con el sistema de justicia
penal gracias
[Aplausos]